hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from round seven
of this year's Tata still chess
tournament it is also the first decisive
game that finished it's vid Gujarati
versus ala fuia viit who out of the six
games that he played he drew all six so
no wins no draws and ala he's been
having a lot of success in the
tournament but he did lose two rounds
ago to the Women's World Champion jujun
then he bounced back by defeating way in
the previous round in that tactical
Skirmish and now we get this game and
it's quite a treat you will enjoy it uh
you know many many a king walk has been
played uh so let's check it out so V it
with the white pieces opens with E4 alza
goes for C5 the Sicilian Defense Knight
F3 D6 and now Pawn to D4 so just a
standard open Sicilian uh sorry about
that uh and C captures on D4 Knight
captures and Knight to F6 we have Knight
to C3 A6 and now Pawn to H3 the Adams
attack against the Knight of Sicilian
and usually E6 or E5 is played sometimes
B5 right away uh but ala goes for Knight
to C6 it is very rare but okay has been
played against um some strong players we
have Bishop to E3 and now Pawn to E5
chasing away the Knight Knight back to
B3 and Bishop to E6 we have Queen to F3
it is preferring to Castle Queen side
and Knight to B4 attacking the C2 Pawn
so of course you Castle Queen side and
now Rook to C8 T are going um for some
pressure here against that C2 Pawn so
now you will have trouble moving the
knight uh King to B1 getting the King
off of the C file and queen to C7 again
if the the Knight on C3 moves just Queen
captures on C2 so here we have Pawn to
A3 chasing away the Knight and this is
where the fun happens ala just plays
Knight captures and C2 it's not a crazy
sacrifice or anything it's the only move
in the position if you don't play Knight
captures on C2 Your Position will just
be worse because if you play Knight back
to C6 you no longer have this pressure
and then the White Knight can unpin by
playing Knight E5 and going after the
black queen so Knight captures on C2 is
best and has been played before by some
strong players hism matulin played it
against karakin voik played it against
Victor Las Nicha and there are other
other lower level games also where the
move was employed so King captures on C2
you have to accept the sacrifice and now
uh the move that you might miss if you
tried playing the sacrifice and that is
Queen to C6 just uh you know playing a
solid move uh putting pressure on that
E4 Pawn as the the the Knight here can't
move so next move Knight captures an E4
is coming and already if you've messed
up the king's position like this and you
grab two pawns for the piece it's like
you haven't even sacrificed anything so
uh vidit has to decide how to go about
this does he defend with Bishop to D3
does he could just go Rook to C1 trying
to move the king and unpin from the C
file uh or does he play Knight to D2
with um a defense to this E4 pawn and
this is what he goes for and this is by
far the best move uh again it has been
played before and there are some like 14
games where this was played and in all
of them D5 was played and D5 is the only
move for black here however alza does
not play Pawn to D5 instead uh he plays
Queen to A4 with check which is very
tricky uh but it's uh uh well
objectively it is the move that loses
the game so interes ly I'm just going to
show what happens if D5 if D5 okay you
can capture on D5 then Knight captures
on D5 and now Rook to C1 and uh only now
do you play Queen to A4 with check and
then after King to B1 uh okay uh you can
play Rook captures on C3 that's kind of
the idea Rook captures on C3 and the
bishop captures on A3 uh not Bishop
captures on A3 but Knight captures on C3
first and after B captures on C3 you get
this position where the queen side has
been busted and and uh black has
sufficient counterplay with the bishop
pair and the queen against the the white
king white in the open H but after ala's
move Queen to A4 check uh it's very much
different and alza spent like 45 minutes
on this move he sacrificed the Knight on
C2 and then after vid defended D4 Pawn
ala spend well maybe even 50 moves on
this queen to A4 move but it doesn't
work and it seems like okay uh vidit can
go King to B1 he can go Pawn to B3 and
those are all very nice moves that hold
for white but the absolute strongest
move is the one from the thumbnail and
that is King to D3 and that is what um
vid it plays uh and yeah like I said
interestingly Queen to A4 is a
completely new move that has never been
played before and it's also the one that
loses the game so usually you'll have a
a move that has never been played before
to serve as a surprise or as an
improvement on the on the already played
positions uh but also you have
situations where a super grandmas plays
it in it's a mve that loses the game but
okay it's easy to say that it loses the
game when the computer tells us yeah
that's that's just losing the game if
you look at the position with your King
on D3 and alza as your opponent it
doesn't feel like you're winning this
game but okay vidit is one of the
strongest players in the world and if it
if there is a defense he will find it
and now uh Rook captures on C3 this is
the only way to continue Pro problem
with a move like let's say Bishop to C4
check Knight captures Queen captures and
C4 check is that you go back and if
Queen to A4 check now you play King to
D2 and okay Queen B3 going after the B2
Pawn uh you can play Rook to C1 uh just
uh preparing to block the the black
queen and if Queen captures on B2 you're
going to play Rook to C2 now Queen
captures on A3 and okay you do have two
connected pass pawns on the queen side
but still uh White is up in material and
will uh win the game if played correctly
so ala has no choice but to continue
happily sacrificing material Rook
captures and C3 B captures and pawn to
D5 now going after that white king but
now vidit plays King to E2 look at this
beautiful king king walk uh de capture
no it's a King march when when it's a
sort of a defensive walk it's a King
march when your opponent forces you to
take a walk in order to Checkmate your
king then it's a king walk I believe so
so we have Queen to G3 and now the king
is on E2 blocking the bishop uh very
hard for V to develop but there's no
good way for um uh for Alesa to actually
continue the attack yeah okay you can
play one one one check but it doesn't do
anything King to E1 and it's a move you
even want to play so Bishop to C4 if
anything uh just uh helps vid develop so
here ala goes Knight to D7 now he wants
to play F5 F4 uh and okay V plays King
to E1 he has to develop his light Square
Bishop Pawn to F5 by alza and now vidit
shows His Brilliant master plan Bishop
to E2 he invites kns Pawn to F4 and it
is the absolute strongest way to play
the problem with Pawn to F4 is that yes
ala will win back material uh but what
does it get you for example captures
captures and captures and how do you how
do you continue playing this uh you're
still down uh in material if if you
count uh everything but um the problem
is your king is also in the center of
the board if you're attacking with black
and it's very easy to go wrong like if
you move the Knight let's say to B6 or
F6 then Queen to B8 check just wins on
the spot uh if you go Bishop to E7 then
just Knight captures an E4 with all
sorts of nasty uh threats like Knight
maybe even just Knight to D6 check
picking up the black queen and even if
you don't win the black queen Knight to
D6 check will be a problem you also
prevent black from castling so you know
for for a game where black is supposed
to be attacking white is attacking very
well so instead after this bishop to E2
move ala just played Pawn to G6 he
probably would have um spent more time
thinking but he was already down to 2
minutes when he played this and this is
move 20 and he's down to 2 minutes on
the clock you need to make 40 moves to
reach additional time control and VI it
has well over half an hour some 35
minutes and okay we have Pawn to H4
again inviting F4 but ites just doesn't
do anything and here Bishop to E7 by Ala
and now he's below the one minute Mark
which means that for the rest of the
game he will pretty much be playing an
increment H and now uh we have uh Bishop
to G5 this sort of allows ala back into
the game it was much safer to play
something like F4 to stop F4 from Mesa
or queen to H3 stopping F4 as the bishop
on E6 would hang but uh he allowed it he
played Bishop to G5 and
now uh Pawn to F4 by Ala uh Bishop
captures we have Pawn captures Queen
captures but now Rook to f8 looking a
little bit better but after Rook to f8
uh uh V is just straight up winning with
Bishop to D5 you're still in the game
but like I said ala was making moves on
increment uh he went too low on time and
um yeah yeah you you defend the pawn and
then you prepare to bring the Rook into
the game but he played Rook to f8 and
now vid just captured D E4 pawn and ala
traded Queens we have captures captures
and now Bishop captures on A3 uh and now
if you count to the material you can see
that uh both players have four pawns
however vidit has a rook uh to ala's
Bishop so not not the best for Al
itively it's completely winning but ala
has to try we have Pawn to H5 and now
Bishop to F5 putting pressure on the
knight uh Rook to D4 just defending we
have Knight to E5 and now H captures on
G6 Ved finding all the all the most
precise moves uh in order to uh take
this uh game to well to to the quickest
possible Victory and now if capture with
the pawn you allow Knight to D6 check
which forces um you to trade down even
further and Bishop C cap on G6 allows
Bishop to H5 which again forces ala to
trade down even further so Knight to C6
attacking The Rook but now just Rook D5
we have King to E7 unpinning hoping to
move the bishop uh but now V just trades
we have captur captures and now Rook to
H7 with check we have King to E6 uh and
now Rook D to D7 uh just going after
that B7 Pawn uh now the situation on the
clock is V it has four minutes on the
clock and alza has two minutes so VI
also uh ran down his clock uh maybe a
bit too much uh and still six more moves
need to be made in order to reach time
control so here Pawn to B5 ala saves the
pawn pawn to F3 and now Rook to C8 uh
just um preparing to move the Knight and
hopefully capture on C3 and now uh you
could just uh go for something like Rook
to C7 uh and force a rook trade but
interestingly vid does not he plays Rook
to B7 uh and now after Pawn to B4 uh we
have C captures on B4 Bishop captures on
B4 with check King to E2 and pawn to A5
and this is now move 38 so two more
moves need to be played in order to
reach time control but ala does have a
defended pass Pawn on A5 so what can vid
it do VI it goes Rook H to G7 again just
goes after the pawn here and you can't
really afford um to lose it because well
let's say you push the a pawn uh means
your Bishop is undefended so that means
Rook captures with check also Rook
captures Knight then even if uh the king
captures Rook that captured Knight you
will pick up the bishop on B4 so all all
absolutely all the tactics work in vid's
favor so ala had to play Knight E5 to
keep an eye on the G6 pawn and now for
move 40 what does vid choose uh he plays
Pawn King to E3 now the only way for
alza to maybe get back into the game
here is if vid played something like G4
and allow something like King to D3 to
D4
but of course viit will now allow that
he played King to E3 and ala played Rook
to C6 just um trying to to to have a
solid position uh but that's even that
is asking too much out of the position
as you are down the exchange so the move
40 has been reached uh but now vid just
plays Pawn to F4 and now all is is out
of U out of ideas as the G6 Pawn will
fall Knight to G4 check was played uh
King to D4 and he was in this position
on move 42 that ala fua resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here so alza really just you know a loss
a win a loss a win and VI it after six
straight straight draws takes down ala
fua who was who was trying to catch up
to Anish giri who's leading the
tournament uh by half a point going into
this round but uh you know uh you will
see in the next video as interesting
turn of events uh uh you you know uh
has occurred and now here you resign
because after King to D4 pretty much
anything you play uh is just lost for
alira let's see he goes uh King to F5 he
wants to maybe grab the pawn here just
Rook G to F7 check and now if you go to
E6 you just get checkmated Knight to G5
with check King to D6 and Rook B to D7
is Checkmate and if you don't if you go
let's say Knight to F6 you want to block
this check uh then Rook to B5 with check
and there are no no no moves here you
have to capture on F4 and then Rook
captures on F6 just wins material Rook
captures Knight captures and now you
will be up a full Rook so alza knew what
he was doing I'm pretty sure not pretty
sure I'm positive he knew about this
sacrifice and that it was possible in
that position and it has been played
before only he mixed up the lines
because you don't sacrifice on C2 and
then spend 50 minutes consider you know
just pondering on on the position what
have I done and then uh you continue uh
by just losing the game so completely
new move and you've lost the game but
yeah what are you going to do very
nicely done by vit U after alzas Knight
captures on C2 and that Queen to A4
check in Precision he played you know an
Immaculate game engine like Precision so
Props divided for taking down alza and
yeah we'll see what uh what happens uh
in the in the rest of the rounds of this
um uh tournament uh so in the rest of
the games of of round seven of this
tournament
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it brilliant stuff by vidit I
would like to thank Brian pin Johan
cence Len Herbert Yun young and
Christopher and Ru berit for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions but mostly
covering this event until it finishes uh
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day next
game is coming up very soon and it
probably will be Anish giri versus um
another abov uh see you
soon